today on stick to football we're kicking
the show off live from Radio row with
our guy Allen Lazard we were talking
about we remember scouting you at Iowa
State where you were just bigger and
stronger than every DB in the big 12 it
felt like now you remember the Green Bay
Packers get to play with Aaron Rodgers
but I want to start off by asking you
about that time to Iowa State because it
seemed like every week you were just
making big play after big play how
different was it for you gone from the
big 12 then you know with the Jags for a
little bit and now with the Packers all
completely different just the the game
and the complexity of the offenses and
defenses and the speed of the game
I'm from caused up to prep the pros this
is so much faster so that transition
kind of just took a little bit you know
which I think is the reason why I was on
the practice squad for a little bit just
to kind of get that the feel of the NFL
and whatnot but once I think obviously I
got a grip of it got back to my normal
comfortable self like he said in college
which I kind of feel like I'm back to
now I might go out there and play how I
want him it was cool for us to see
obviously we watched ulong college saw
you at the Senior Bowl and you did go
undrafted but we knew the talent was
always there what was it like does that
give you a different edge when you're an
undrafted guy because now I mean you're
doing better than a lot of guys in that
class that were drafted in rounds you
didn't want to three and on yeah yeah I
mean um going undrafted and what not
been getting cut almost conscious a
reality check honestly you know I think
that was a point in my life where I
realized my career could be ending soon
so I really locked in you know really
kind of honed in on my craft and really
took this took my job series every
single day and I think that's what led
to my production this year now I would
say you were starting about a lot of
talent I mean probably the most talent
the Cyclones have ever had you a keen
butler David Montgomery and you guys
might not all been on the field all the
time together but going against those
guys now that you're in an NFL locker
room can you look back and be like man
we had some players there at Iowa State
absolutely absolutely you know I
definitely have a lot of credit to my
success for or I would say success
especially my senior on to David I'm
when he first you know showed to the
program very young very quiet we just
came and worked his ass off every single
day and I think that energy and his
demeanor was very contagious for me as
well as everyone else on the team so it
definitely um has had an effect on me
and where I am today and now you have to
see him as a Chicago Bear I know - and
I'll get the most right
keep that posture exactly and you played
for a coach that has gotten some NFL
feels and Matty Campbell a lot of
experience there and then this year at
the Packers you're with a first-year guy
obviously in the floor what's the
difference between those guys and both
those guys are winners what are some of
the things that make them similar um I
think just their fiery coaching ability
you know that is so very passionate
about the games obviously they're both
very young um you know coach Campbell in
college and then social work now on the
weak but just how they how they approach
every single day and just the their
demeanor and it's really easy to relate
to the both of them just because a lot
younger than most coaches and you know I
think they just bring that juice and
energy and you know really just do a
good job of game play well as Aaron
Rodgers really liked cuz you know you
hear the rumors that man this guy's kind
of a prick you know like nobody like
wants to deal with Aaron Rodgers but
he's getting older now
maybe he's calming down a little bit I
say older were the same damn age but
what does he really like for you as a
young guy coming in um he's everything
that I needed to know to have my success
he kind of just took me under his wings
when I first got there um you know I
didn't really say much I just kind of
worked worked my butt off and just kind
of like you don't let him do his thing
and um I think I was able to gain his
trust throughout that process and to
show him that I have the ability to play
yeah it's not bad going from cutting
Jacksonville to playing with a
hall-of-famer yeah in Aaron Rodgers
right so were you upset when it's like
oh like that's like she cut nobody was
get fired yeah but then you go to Green
Bay yeah I was deciding between him and
Blake bortles so yeah I think you did
the right thing and when you looking at
it when do you think you turned the
corner with Aaron because there was a
point where you go from you know being a
guy on the back end of the depth chart
to being the number two guy where he's
looking your way and he's just thrown it
up there giving you a chance to make a
play because you were on that level
where you're going up and winning the
football was there a certain point in
the season where you're like okay now
I'm the guy especially when Devante was
out for a while um I would say there's a
particular point necessarily honestly
I've always felt that confidence in
myself yeah just being that guy and I
mean like why don't you throw me the
ball um kind of having that mentality
but you have to be that way yeah yeah I
think you know I just go out there try
to win every single rep
who I'm going against her you know if
it's a bad coverage or not so I want to
kind of have a productive outcome you
know I think it was kind of just towards
the end of the season November December
when I started to kind of really get
into my my groove like I said you know
how I felt like I was playing back in
college and I was getting that really
good chemistry with him of just knowing
when he's gonna throw the ball knowing
what he's seeing from the defense and
you know what he wants out of me
I know it's probably this go back to
that 2018 draft I expected you to be
drafted I think Connor expected I'm sure
you expected you to be drafted what was
that like to just sit there and watch
like I mean we all know how it is like
you're watching receivers come off the
board and you're like are you are you
kidding me like I know I'm better than
that guy what was that like for you to
be sitting there on Saturday realizing
that it wasn't gonna happen
oh it was a humbling moment for sure you
know I had a little little draft party
whatever at b-dubs I'm back at Ames but
uh but yeah it was just a very humbling
moment just realizing I like I thought I
was a lot better than what I was and you
know so I just kind of just took that
all in you kind of just realized I could
sink or swim in it was like you said
like maybe I'm not as good as I think I
am or does it put you in the okay those
32 general managers just aren't smart
like I'm gonna prove those guys
absolutely you know I definitely have
that demeanor and that ship to me every
single day still you know I'm like I'm
gonna forget about going undrafted in
one I like for me you know that was my
childhood dream and there's long one
chance to get to achieve that so I
didn't get a B and I was like dang so
now I'm just rying to make up for it a
lot of first-year NFL coaches they
almost get a pass that first year a lot
of people buying that hey this might be
a rebuild year or this might be a
transition year and for you guys this
year with Coach Lafleur you go out and
win 13 games you make the playoffs you
make a lot of noise I think honestly
maybe not to you guys but to the general
public you exceeded expectations how do
you build off of that what might be an
overachieving year or a year we're now
next year it's pretty much looked at hey
we can make it to the Super Bowl next
year how do you build off something like
that I mean playing for the Green Bay
Packers that's the that's sustained at
every single good point um so I mean
just having this year that we had
obviously came up one game short and
whatnot but we're very satisfied of
where we were for the expectations and
really this whole year
just kind of kick getting comfortable in
the offense you know obviously Aaron has
had his system you know for 1314 years
and now get Khosla for bringing in a new
offense and whatnot and cuz it's those
two guys are trying to feel each other
out obviously me playing I'm a new guy
I'm a lot of new faces so I mean this
year was honestly to the uf kinda skin
comfortable and establishing the
foundation so I'm really excited about
next year of just be able to hone in on
the plays the concepts and just kind of
understand I mean you're not coming in
late like you'll be you'll be there all
year you know you have the offseason
program how much do you pay attention to
the noise that if you read mock drafts
or you know pits into the draft stuff
everybody's like Packers got a draft for
receiver we got a draft a receiver you
pay attention to any of that Oh a little
bit but like not the same time because
like like what else would I expect it's
not like they're gonna like not try a
bad receivers right yeah it's not you
only have one receiver so it's like you
know there's always gonna be competition
and you know I'm gonna I'm gonna welcome
any other competition to my room cuz I
think that's gonna make me better I'm
having guys like Devante in my room has
very very much elevated my game just
watching him every single day on how he
goes about his work and just you know
just is his releases are scary yeah yeah
that's actually something I want to ask
you about like what can you learn from a
player like that where he's a guy still
a younger guy I mean he's in his prime
now but is there anything is he you know
somebody that you have learned from more
so than other NFL receiver he's been
around I mean thinking about it through
your ear he's probably the best you've
been around so far yeah yeah I mean even
in Jacksonville you know I learned a lot
from DB Westbrook can I just watching
him he's a completely different body
type is yeah - so I'm just watching how
he how he operated down there as well as
Mark Easley and Donte Moncrief only my
boy DJ my what DJ shark not agree really
good year yeah happy for him Pro Bowl
and everything yeah but yeah just
watching Devon - every single day you
know I think one thing that I realized
when I got to the Packers is that every
rep and practice is a game run and I
think not that I didn't have that
mindset before but this here it's visual
and I'm watching him every single day
take those game reps really made me
elevate my game as far as going hard
every single day in practice and just
really getting better at my craft are
you a little sad you get to play Minshew
coz he's crazy
yeah a little bit think we would have
had a fun time for sure what may be more
fun off the field but definitely someone
on the field look surfers bar right is
Lambeau the most like legendary place
you've played in so far as their
different feel to it um is there a more
legendary place I don't think so like
maybe the Colosseum in Rome so we do
something called the tailgate tour right
here where we go to both college and NFL
games we probably had about eight this
year I try to go to visit the best
places in football all across and we
always circle like we're gonna we had to
do lamb but we got to do Lambeau so
hopefully next year maybe you convinced
and the fans there
it feels very traditional football it is
it's very it's very a homey feeling when
you get there you know everyone's just
you just feel the energy from the crowd
the people in the stadium and then just
being inside the stadium it's just the
lights would attend the field at night
especially on the snow this is if you
played at Iowa State so like that
climate change is not a shock to you
like it might be to some other it's not
but at the same time at the same time
and I would definitely gets Iowa gets up
there especially walk into class before
we let you go because we know you got to
do the car wash here you got to go do
like 40 of these today we have to ask
are you picking in the Super Bowl and
why you can't just get out of here it's
like I think I have to like I'm gonna
switch my answer throughout the day
we've been here a lot of people don't
we won't go check other people well
that's the thing I've been you know I've
been thinking about it because it's like
NSE I mean the Niners 9 you are you mad
about it or you rip your conference
exactly
I like Patrick Mahone you gotta get the
mo Holmes haircut yeah yeah I'm gonna go
49ers though ok that's my guess I'm a
bettin man
yeah I'm not what you're not cuz you're
an NFL player exact don't get in trouble
don't don't be doing that alright man
thanks for your time we're looking
forward seeing what you do next year and
me too [ __ ] all those doubters exactly
thanks out on any other show over yeah
thanks man guys we are happy to sit down
with one of the best running backs in
NFL history mister
Eddie George the guy who only player did
not get the Madden curse George but
historic career at Ohio State with the
Tennessee Titans so thank you for coming
on thanks to Jack Daniels you guys are
hooking people up with some free we're
not free but cheaper uber ride cheaper
uber rides everyone over 21 across the
u.s. over 21 we're promoting the drink
responsibly to give them $5 with uber
and it's a great deal so as you're out
there having a good time at these Super
Bowl parties or at the game or wherever
you may be of course you're gonna
indulge and have a JD is along the lines
and you just want to drink responsibly
says that's what promoting today and in
a commercial will be out on Super Bowl
Sunday promoting just that Eddie as we
watch a guy like Derek Henry have such a
good season and everybody talks about
hey is it different running back and you
guys have a really similar build
honestly do you think we're gonna see
teams now be more willing to give the
running back with that kind of build and
running style a chance it felt like we
went back to guys that were 5 10 to 20
or these quicker scat backs and now we
got a power back like Henry like you
were do you think this is gonna change
how teams view running backs coming into
the NFL yeah unless unless you have a
Tom Brady yes you have a Patrick mahomes
unless you have a special quarterback
yeah I think you're gonna see more teams
try to find that like San Francisco they
don't have one guy but they have a power
running game that resembles that it gets
you a long way as you can see you know
defense great running game special teams
they travel they play well December too
late months and so forth and that's what
the Titans had and Derek Cambria had the
hot hand
he was imposing his will on defenders
the Titans were complemented with a
great defense or opportunistic defense
and a quarterback who didn't make
mistakes and that can win you a lot of
ballgames and get you deep into the
playoffs so I think that philosophy
absolutely now the question is moving
forward how they're gonna build around
that so I've always said you have to be
able to run the football in December in
January to win a championship so you
would pay a guy like that right because
I would yeah do you worry he's a special
back with the unique status
skills these get paid unique way do you
worry about the carries I know you
thought some you've spoken about with
your career like you may be high amount
of carries does that contribute to
longevity do you think we're doing we're
I mean what does I mean listen we
understand that the running back
position
is a short shelf life yeah okay so you
have to maximize that
that being said he's the focal point of
your office to stray away from that
didn't you lose your identity so you
have to be willing to pay for that
during however long that's gonna be
listen he doesn't have a lot of treadle
attires he's been in the league but for
formulas fifth year first two years but
time
Marco Murray really was last year and a
half that we're starting to see so his
upside is tremendous III think he has an
1800 yard 2,000 yard season ahead of
them next year
MVP type season if they get the right
pieces and parts around him so I think
you must look at that to say man he's
got a lot more left in him maybe five
six seven years of great productivity
and you want to you want to pay somebody
unfairly so I wouldn't try to skate
around it if you're the Titans are
really serious about taking this to the
next level recognize it for what it is
don't play games
you know find the win win of course you
want to be able to cut cost and really
not maximize the opportunity but you
want to find where that wind when is
where everybody's happy and take care of
your best player so what would you do if
Mike Vrabel and John Robinson call you
and say hey what do we do about Ryan
Tannehill wear it look I mean he gave
them the spark they needed when they put
him in I think down the stretch we saw
that there were some limitations that
offense because they couldn't throw the
ball
what are you doing Ryan Tannehill I
would still allow him to develop he's
developed a chemistry he developed a
spark and there's a momentum there with
him that in the offseason has a full
offseason to be a full starter and
really dedicate his offseason to that I
think he can mature into that type of he
can listen he could throw the football
right and he's healthy he's healthy I
think now we get the coaching up on you
know getting rid of the ball a little
bit sooner that takes so many sacks and
that's more of a coaching thing but
but I would I would find a way to keep
chanting Hill and Derrick Henry together
because that should make any you bring
another quarterback then you start from
scratch you know there just talks about
Tom Brady coming on paper that sounds
great I think in terms of PS sells and
selling seats and all of that getting
the fanfare really excited yeah that
sounds great
well how does that affect the office now
you have to change the office to some
degree and it's not going to be you're
not going to have the threat of
Tannehill running with his legs to help
Derek out yeah Kanye's big to know these
big so I'm more prone to think that
they're kenri in Tannehill are a good
pair that to really harp and focus on
and maximize those opportunities to
cultivate that relationship right there
looking ahead to the Super Bowl I think
it's amazing watching this 49ers team
just to see the way they run the pass
because they're doing Shanahan gets
reputation outside zone inside zone but
we're seeing gap trap we're seeing so
many different things from this team
yeah what have you seen personally that
just makes this run game go doesn't
matter who's in the backfield for them
yes it can be Chuck Muncie it can be
rahul jovan rahim off the street yeah
they're cutting the ball down your
throat and it's all based off of the old
run scheme that was from the Broncos
yeah when Terrell Davis had his run in
late 90s there were thousands and that
was lethal I mean there's nothing you
could do they had an answer for
everything and it doesn't matter if you
have nine in the box eight the box it
doesn't matter they're gonna find a way
to create that the numbers but the
offensive line they're so in sync that
they're create a new line of scrimmage
and they're playing well together and
they're sync so that really makes it
hard on the defense to stop that once
that running game gets up incoming
doesn't matter who's in the game they're
they're coming downhill on you a lot of
people say that it doesn't matter who is
that running back in San Francisco but
when Kyle has had a special running back
they've had amazing seasons well in your
prime how many yards could you rush for
on that Niners offense you know I don't
know maybe 400 come on you're being
humble you know it's such a great
offense I think that makes you a really
great running game
is to have the element of balance when
you're able to throw the football and
stretch the field you have weapons on
the outside you have a nice tight end
and kettle I think that's an important
component to a run game is it's McCann
you can run for 1,500 to 2,000 yards
their type of offense if you're you're
healthy and you can have success in
front we know you got a lot of places to
be you're a wanted man thank you for
stopping by don't forget Jack Daniels
ran everybody else pawns to drink
responsibly yes he looks right at me
when he said that like you know ya got
this feeling about you like and I'm
gonna post up and I'm gonna get Jack
Daniels runny and keep Rob flat on
another great interview today Darius
slate in New York giant white receiver a
guy that we just evaluated last years
right in the draft class in a great wide
receiver class man thanks for coming
I'll stick football and I'm gon
appreciate you guys having me Darius
obviously you know I've been a couple
months since I last talked to you but
you finished the season really really
strong surprised a lot of people being a
fifth round pick and then you go on and
you have almost 800 receiving yards
almost ten touchdowns
what was this rookie season like for you
did you exceed your personal
expectations and just what are you
looking forward to next year with Daniel
Jones and you guys being a you know
big-time connection yeah you know I
definitely I definitely I cost people by
surprise for sure like being a fifth
round pick you know they kind of don't
expect that little production out of you
but you know I always knew I could play
ball and I can make plays obviously it's
kind of it's kind of hard to know how
good you're gonna be especially where
you go into a new level you don't know
anything about but you know I felt like
I could play felt like I'd compete and
you know I'm just looking forward to
growing within he's a young really
talented quarterback in you know I'm
blessed to have the opportunity to play
with him how much harder is the NFC East
in the SEC I think is the NFL in general
is a lot harder yeah because you just
you know the SEC is a tough leak but um
there's still some you know there's
Arkansas there's low yeah a little a
little lull in the league but you know
the NF
it's like every week you know there's
you know fans people on the outside they
like oh that's a bad team's a bad team
they get on the field and it's like well
they're still professionals you know
they're still good so it's a little bit
tougher yeah yeah you don't get your
Arkansas Vanderbilt on a matter like
that who's the toughest corner you went
against this year probably Stephon
Gilmore yeah he's pretty good I mean how
hard is that because you know Wheaton
neither of us played in the NFL
obviously and so when you get outside
like you've been watching this guy
forever
you've probably like played against him
in Madden you know and you're like oh
[ __ ] like that's really Stephon Gilmore
and he's about to press me yeah what is
that moment like when you have that
realization it's kind of just a I kind
of think the way I thought to myself was
I was like I whatever my best is I gotta
throw it you know I was all I'm thinking
is like just don't get jammed up on
national television because we played
him on Thursday night so I was like yeah
okay I'm whatever I'm doing I'm throwing
the best I got yeah that's the way the
judge pick anything up from Golden Tate
this year you know looking forwards a
veteran wide receiver anything you can
learn from a guy like that yeah
definitely especially just because he uh
he plays the game so we're and you know
I asked him about it all the time and
you know it's I guess it's kind of most
things that's easier said than done but
um he just the way he moves to zones and
catches the ball and avoids hits you
know it's it's been it's been a blessing
to be able to play with some I like that
your wife's ear room was pretty banged
up this past year is that something you
guys talk about like next year of
everybody's healthy that you could have
something special there I mean Evan is a
great tight end when he's on the field
chef's there is a good player but but a
lot of those guys were paying up which
did give you an opportunity but when you
guys look at yourself being full
strength next year how good could this
group be I think it'd be really good you
know I think I think you know definitely
the more weapons it's kind of like you
know see the teams in Super Bowl now you
know that all those weapons you know
people how do you defend it you know I
think we have the same kind of dynamic
you know you got a real tight in a real
running back and some really good
receivers and you know I definitely
think once we get everybody you know
back and health only feel at the same
time I think will be really hard to
defend
have you gotten to meet your judge it
now I have
he looks super intense I'll say that but
you know obviously probably pretty
excited for the higher and and Jason
Garrity's your offensive coordinator but
looking back on this year you did have a
great season under Pat Shermer what were
you able to either learn from him or
what were the reasons that you got to
excel in that offense I think the
biggest reason is coach Herman came
things very simple you know our office
wasn't super complicated it wasn't you
know rocket scientist rocket science you
know it was pretty simple so it was easy
to play fast and I think that was one of
the biggest things that helped me play
well Wendy what do you know about Joe
judge because I'll be honest we were
doing the podcast when he got hired and
we were like oh we need to take a break
and Google this guy because I thought he
was getting a Mississippi State job you
know he was gonna be the SEC all of a
sudden he's the Giants head coach what
have you tried to learn about him in the
last couple weeks here I don't know too
much about him I know he's special teams
guy you know my quarterback college
quarterback Gerry plays to the Patriots
so you know I called him I had some kind
of he's as a person you know he's a good
guy he's a southern guy so yes some of
that southern hospitality to him but you
know just looking forward to you know
playing what I'm seeing what he brings
to our team what are you you mention
Jarrett and I want to ask you about that
because the Tom Brady owner hurt Tom
Brady's free agent nobodies were talking
about that but yeah what else didn't
feel you know because it's shocking you
back home when you guys were both coming
out the draft it's like you you were so
much better than sometimes what the
numbers look like on the field and
whatever your offensive line style
offense all those issues but what do you
think you think Jarrett can be the guy
to take over for Tom Brady yeah I think
Jarrett has the kind of mold of a
patriot quarterback you know he's a guy
that's gonna go in he's gonna study like
crazy he's gonna study the defense and I
think that's the biggest thing up
there's Tom Brady has the brain to run
that operate you'll got the brain you're
out of luck yeah yeah operation like
that you'll got to bring her out of look
so I think I think Jarrett's got the
brain obviously has the arm town to make
all the throws but specifically I think
he has the brain force so you know you
know who see we'll see if he gets his
chance what's the one thing with Daniel
Jones that really jumped out to you this
year just poise yeah you know even in
even in town she was under he made a lot
of throws under duress you know a lot of
throws as he's getting hit and
you know it's easy for a guy to sit back
there and make throws all day good for
two but you know in detection breaks
down plays break down you know it takes
a lot of mental fortitude to keep
standing there making throws how much
attention do you pay now that you're in
the league to mock drafts and everybody
says the Giants are gonna go off into
tackle do you look at that stuff and say
okay pleat like we need a little help
for then we need to help for sake want
or just ignore all of it yeah I don't
get it too too much because I can't
draft anybody control what you but yeah
obviously no every team has needs going
into every offseason so you know
obviously hope you know whatever needs
they feel like we have get them filled
did you look at it last year to kind of
see that guy right where am I expected
to end up where do people think I'm
gonna go things like that oh yeah of
course you know I was in the draft so
you know I wanted you know yeah it's
hard not to like that yeah how good does
it feel to not have like the combine
looming this year and all those pressure
things like you could just go into the
season as your second years in New York
giant I mean for a lot of the games this
year you were the guy in that offense
you know how is it feel just going into
year two and not having that nonsense
during the spring where you could just
train instead oh it's great you know it
was a stressful time it seems that way
yeah especially because I was
underclassmen so the combine invite
doesn't come for us until I think it
came in like late January or something
yeah so it's like you just wait wait
wait and praying to God you get the
email um so I was first level of stress
and then once he got it then it was like
okay now I got to go out here and I got
to perform be on point so definitely
glad to go through that process
I mean you ran a 4-3 nine so I think it
went well I would say think you went
alright but I think that even surprised
a lot of people I remember being
surprised like oh damn I know it was
that fast like yeah how much of that do
you feel like for you for Jarrett with
the Auburn offense I mean you guys were
held back I can say you I don't know if
you can say it but I can say you guys
were held back a little bit was that
frustrating and go through the process
and get slept on a little bit
I was definitely frustrating going
through the process you know because
obviously like colleagues say control
you can control you just kind of make
the best of whatever your situation is
you know obviously as people come from
all over the country big 12 where's 7 on
7 and it's like you know they've got a
million career receiving yards it's like
well they throw the ball 40 times a game
and you know
as you see just a rushing leak it
doesn't matter really what school you're
at but you know it was it was it was a
little frustrating but you know
obviously both made it through it okay
yeah definitely some more of your former
teammates gonna be joining you in the
league pretty soon we've been excited
talking about them with Derrick brown
and Marlin Davidson specifically yeah it
had just how special are those guys I
mean we were down to the Senior Bowl
Marlin Davidson for the practices he was
in took over and we know Derrick is
probably gonna be a top 15 picking a
really special player yeah
they're both really really special
players you know it was a lot of to me
they're like the underclassmen that came
in but you know those are those are my
little brothers mean I prayed a best for
them I hope they both get drafted hi
wherever you know somewhere that they
can go and be successful because you
know they're both really good players
and I look forward to see him in his
League what key tell us about Noah
obviously you guys try battles down
practice didn't have a pick this year
but is just you if you watch a play like
pass breakups are there speeds there
what was it like a practice going
against him it's actually weird cuz Noah
actually came into receiver so I
actually played a year in the same room
as him before he moved to DB so you know
sometimes I forget that people asking
about him yeah he plays receiver you
know it's been fun to watch him make
that position transition and you know
hopefully hope the best room to in a
draft yeah what's one thing you're
looking you know towards improving on
this year with the Giants obviously you
guys want to win more games but yeah you
lost a Kwan for a stretch last year you
have a quarterback that's in year two
you're a big piece of the offense you're
in year two you know how do you outline
your offseason go what do we really need
to step up next year um I think just
kind of focus on myself better myself
you know I still got to work on some
fine-tuning things in a rout running
game like I said stuff like that like go
to Tate and Sterling do you know just
little things getting in have your
brakes a little bit quicker just
definitely stuff I got to work on what's
your offseason playing like so last year
stressful with the combine and you're
training for that this is your first
real offseason as an NFL player
what you gonna do yeah yeah the month of
January I've been at home good for you
yeah but now I was like you know what
this is a long recovery yeah you know I
had some lagging nagging injuries I was
like I just need some time to relax but
they hit the ground running here pretty
soon probably after this and just get
back at random
have you spent any time in New York City
yet uh no actually I left I left pretty
quickly after New Year's mark right
maybe near - yeah it's a little code up
there for me yeah it's overwhelming to
know definitely all right man we'll
enjoy your Super Bowl week who you
pickin by the way you asked us a lot get
ready yeah I'll cop out you know it
Miko's from Georgia I'm from Georgia so
I'll go to the Chiefs and I'm good with
that pick good enough logic with it's a
1/2 point spread nobody knows they're
gonna win all right Darius Leighton
check this guy out one of the best
up-and-coming receivers in the NFL and
we'll be back Ryder this on stick to
football right guys that is our show
today from Radio Road thank you to Allen
Lazard thank you to Eddie George who was
an amazing wild drink response he was
very concerned about you in his funny
because we've never talked before I
don't know how he knew I don't know he's
drink hey I know he's seen you somewhere
people call when they don't call Maddy
Mills they call mr. Miami right exactly
yeah you wouldn't know it but it's a
thing and and thanks to Darius Lane
we've had had some offensive players
today yes awesome and we got a lot lined
up for the one skin we're not done we
got a lot left but you know done those
first come first serve those the first
three we had and they were awesome to
talk to you yeah and I don't want to
spoil anything because schedules change
around here so we're not we're gonna
take but one thing it is locked in
Saturday at 1:00 o'clock we're enough
Kenny Vaccaro at a fake address yeah one
one one one Lincoln yeah I don't believe
it that's there I'm gonna show up we
haven't gone to check it out yet so we
haven't confirmed it's real but the
pictures look really cool in the content
coming out is really cool on PR gridiron
mellow we'll be here we'll be hanging
out with Kenny Vaccaro you'll be able to
listen to that as the Monday morning
podcast and then right next week we get
back to normal a little bit I have a
seven or I mock drive coming up Monday
morning so the Tuesday show will be me
kind of breaking that down some of the
the pic thoughts or addressing some
concerns about controversial pics and
then some of our interviews from here
this week at radio row so it's going to
be a good time we've got a couple more
interviews to knock out so we will talk
to you all real soon